FEMALE SPEAKER: Hi, everybody.
So thank you so
much for being here.
Today we are absolutely
delighted to welcome Chef Alain
Ducasse, one of the
most renowned chefs
of his generation.
And he's here to talk to us
about his book "J'aime London,"
which he's recently launched.
Chef Ducasse is a
restaurant creator,
a contemporary innkeeper, an
educator, and a publisher.
And over the past
30 years, he has
developed a unique
savoir-faire which
has helped to shape the
contemporary art of living
and eating.
And he is joined by his
old friend and fellow
chef, Michel Roux
Jr, who has kindly
written the forward to
the book "J'aime London."
And he will be conducting
the conversation.
And he's also almost fresh from
the London Marathon on Sunday.
So if he hobbles onto the stage,
then you'll know why that is.
So welcome to Chef
Ducasse and Chef Roux.
[APPLAUSE]
ALAIN DUCASSE: [SPEAKING FRENCH]
MICHEL ROUX JR:
Hello, everybody.
Thankfully there were
no steps to climb up.
A nice easy, easy up
onto the stage here,
and a nice, comfy chair.
Good.
Thank you.
Thank you for coming here today.
Thank you for having us.
My friend Alain and fellow chef,
god to a lot of young chefs,
and someone that is
highly, highly respected.
An all time great.
So we're going to get to know
a little bit more about Alain--
about his philosophy.
And although he
understands English,
he says his English
isn't that good.
But he can say a
few words, so we're
going to try and coax a little
bit of English out of him.
But I'm here to translate and
to ask him a few questions.
ALAIN DUCASSE: [SPEAKING FRENCH]
MICHEL ROUX JR: I will.
I will do my best.
ALAIN DUCASSE: [SPEAKING FRENCH]
MICHEL ROUX JR: I
will do my best.
So Alain, first of all,
I want to find out--
or we would like to
find out-- a little bit
about you, how you started.
It's well documented about me.
I was nearly born in a kitchen.
But I would like to
know, and everybody here
would like to know,
how you started.
How Alain Ducasse, a little
boy, got into cooking.
[SPEAKING FRENCH]
ALAIN DUCASSE: [SPEAKING FRENCH]
MICHEL ROUX JR: So Alain said,
like a lot of French kids,
their grandmother
was cooking at home.
Grandma's cooking.
I remember my grandma's cooking.
It was beautiful.
Beautiful.
And that is what inspired him.
He was born on a farm in
the southwest of France.
He has the accent.
I don't know if you clocked
that one, the accent
of the southwest of
France, probably one
of the most beautiful
regions in France.
Very rich.
[FRENCH]
ALAIN DUCASSE: [SPEAKING FRENCH]
MICHEL ROUX JR: A real idyllic
childhood in a village.
Being able to go to your local
farm or shop to buy the goods.
[FRENCH] as we call it
in France-- real land.
And the beauty of
that part of France
is that it has great
sunshine, but it also
has the sea air, as well.
So it has proper seasons
and it's very rich and lush.
And the ingredients that
come there are beautiful.
ALAIN DUCASSE: [SPEAKING FRENCH]
MICHEL ROUX JR: I
think that's where
his inspiration comes from.
And it is from
those early years,
and being able to pick
up wonderful ingredients,
and then being inspired by them
to create beautiful dishes.
But dishes that have a
meaning, that have an origin.
[FRENCH]
ALAIN DUCASSE: [SPEAKING FRENCH]
MICHEL ROUX JR:
[SPEAKING FRENCH]
ALAIN DUCASSE: [SPEAKING FRENCH]
MICHEL ROUX JR: So he's keen.
He said he wasn't
learning enough so
he escaped the village
and went to a hotel
catering school, of which
there are many in France.
ALAIN DUCASSE: [SPEAKING FRENCH]
MICHEL ROUX JR: In Bordeaux.
MICHEL ROUX JR:
[SPEAKING FRENCH]
ALAIN DUCASSE: [SPEAKING FRENCH]
MICHEL ROUX JR:
He's just mentioned
some of the greats of France
in passing, in passing.
Michel Guerard in
the southwest-- one
of the most beautiful places.
If you haven't been to
Michel Guerard before,
go and spend a week there.
Eugenie-les-Bains--
it is outstanding.
I remember my best
ever dessert-- sorry,
but I'm going-- my
best ever dessert,
and it has yet to be
topped, was quite simply
a wild strawberry tart.
That sounds just
banal, doesn't it?
[FRENCH]
ALAIN DUCASSE: [SPEAKING FRENCH]
MICHEL ROUX JR: It
was extraordinary.
So sorry.
Eugenie-les-Bains--
worked there.
And then you worked
for Alain Chapel.
I just missed Alain.
I think Alain finished in
August and I started work
in September.
ALAIN DUCASSE: [SPEAKING FRENCH]
MICHEL ROUX JR: He's a
year or two older than me.
We worked in the
same place for Alain
Chapel-- an extraordinary chef.
What did Alain Chapel--
ALAIN DUCASSE: [SPEAKING FRENCH]
was a perfect experience.
[SPEAKING FRENCH]
MICHEL ROUX JR: The
experience at Alain Chapel
taught him rigor.
But also the fact that
Alain Chapel was way ahead
of his years, and he was a
modern chef of that era-- quite
extraordinary.
I learned well, I always
go back to Alain Chapel.
For me he was my
strongest influence.
ALAIN DUCASSE:
Yeah, for me, too.
MICHEL ROUX JR: And I
think Alain, as well.
A great man.
ALAIN DUCASSE: [SPEAKING FRENCH]
MICHEL ROUX JR: Alain
Chapel was haute cuisine--
the true meaning of it-- in
the same way as haute couture
is now, and will always exist,
and should always exist.
So he really was the
benchmark, Alain Chapel.
Sadly no longer open, and
sadly no longer with us.
[FRENCH] Monaco?
ALAIN DUCASSE: [SPEAKING FRENCH]
MICHEL ROUX JR: It
was a huge gamble.
The Prince Rainier, in Monaco,
got Alain as a young chef
and said, look,
this is what I want.
I want three Michelin Stars and
you've got four years to do it,
and threw down the gauntlet.
And Alain achieved the
three stars in 33 months.
So he certainly
did achieve that.
And it's still going strong.
I was very fortunate
and honored to be there
for the birthday celebrations
two years ago, now, wasn't it?
It goes so quickly.
Truly extraordinary.
And it is, again, I
urge you-- this is
one place where
you've got to go.
It's got to be on
your bucket list.
Go to Monaco, and go to Alain's
restaurant there, Le Louis XV.
It is extraordinary,
extraordinary.
And [INAUDIBLE] its
longevity, its consistency--
that is the hallmark
of a great man
and the hallmark of
a great restaurant,
is that it is consistent--
consistently good,
delivering the goods
time and time again.
Monaco, [FRENCH].
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
ALAIN DUCASSE: [SPEAKING FRENCH]
MICHEL ROUX JR:
So his philosophy
behind that cuisine--
Riviera Cuisine-- was
to take humble goods and very
classic, instantly recognizable
dishes-- such as bouillabaisse,
an aioli, or the dishes
that you would recognize on a
menu in the south of France,
in that area-- and to make
that into haute gastronomy--
something that is worthy
of three Michelin Stars.
So using the great produce--
of which there are so many,
but you have to find
them-- and making them
into exquisite food,
exquisite dishes,
but still with that
philosophy of Riviera Cuisine.
ALAIN DUCASSE: [SPEAKING FRENCH]
MICHEL ROUX JR:
[SPEAKING FRENCH]
ALAIN DUCASSE: [SPEAKING FRENCH]
MICHEL ROUX JR:
[SPEAKING FRENCH]
ALAIN DUCASSE: [SPEAKING FRENCH]
MICHEL ROUX JR: The politics
of the Michelin guide--
I don't think we're
going to go into that.
But Alain was explaining
that he got a phone call
from Joel Robuchon,
another amazing chef,
to announce that he was
retiring and that if Alain would
be interested in taking his
place in a restaurant in Paris.
And then he said, well,
just over the phone,
he couldn't believe that
Robuchon was phoning.
He said, well, yeah, why not.
So off he went to Paris.
And the Michelin
Guide removed one star
from one of his
restaurants just because he
was moving as a chef.
That's the politics
of the Michelin Guide,
and they do work
in mysterious ways.
He got it back instantly,
which he deserved.
And that was the beginning of
the Alain Ducasse adventure
and venturing out worldwide.
So many restaurants
in Paris, Monaco,
and all over the
world, including
London, of course, as well.
A little bit about
Alain and going global--
or as you call it, glocal--
ALAIN DUCASSE: [SPEAKING FRENCH]
MICHEL ROUX JR: I think
this is fantastic.
I love this.
Glocal.
It really does-- it's perfect.
And I don't think it's
just for us in cooking.
I think it's in any business.
Wherever you go, you may be a
global brand-- in his instance,
he is a global brand
in his own right--
but he will use local produce,
local workforce where possible,
and not forgetting he is
cooking for a local customer.
So in America, he will
be cooking for Americans.
In London, he's
cooking for Londoners,
or for British people.
In Paris, for Parisians.
And that is very important.
And it's the key to
success in most businesses.
If he were to force or ram
down the throat-- in New York,
for example-- typically French,
and have it all imported
and all that, it
probably wouldn't work.
Or it wouldn't be
as well-respected.
And I think that is really the
key to the Alain Ducasse brand
and the strength--
his glocal vision.
And I think he should be really
highly commended for that.
ALAIN DUCASSE: [SPEAKING FRENCH]
MICHEL ROUX JR: I think
what Alain has just
said there is very
important, as well.
I think all great chefs are
teachers-- natural teachers--
and want to pass
on their knowledge.
Alain has written many,
many books-- great books.
And it's all part of his psyche.
It's part of him being
a very generous chef.
He has cooking schools, as well.
It's all part of his philosophy.
And my father and uncle-- the
Roux Scholarship, for example--
that's been going on for 31
years helping British chefs
to achieve their goals.
We all too often see young
chefs who are in the limelight
and trying to get the glory,
but don't think of the future.
And the future is
passing on your knowledge
and being generous
with your time.
And I think that
is something which
Alain is very generous with
his time, and very generous
with his staff, as well.
ALAIN DUCASSE: [SPEAKING FRENCH]
MICHEL ROUX JR: Yes, absolutely.
Cooking is happening
all over the world.
It doesn't matter where you're
from-- on what continent, what
the color of your skin
is-- everybody cooks,
and everybody has a heritage.
And that's certainly
very important.
And it's so beautiful.
But cooking evolves and
moves-- moves at a steady pace,
and moves with us.
And it's up to us, as chefs,
to express that, as well.
[FRENCH]
ALAIN DUCASSE: [SPEAKING FRENCH]
MICHEL ROUX JR: (LAUGHING)
[SPEAKING FRENCH]
When I was an apprentice
in Paris at the age of 16,
my French was absolutely pants.
It was crap.
And my boss there,
in Paris, used
to call me "le roast beef."
Roast beef.
So we've touched upon
your global vision.
We've touched a little
bit upon your origins
and what makes Alain Ducasse
the great chef he is.
But what about your new
and latest creation here?
"J'aime London."
"I Love London."
ALAIN DUCASSE: [SPEAKING FRENCH]
MICHEL ROUX JR: It was-- he's
done Paris, Monaco, New York--
ALAIN DUCASSE: [SPEAKING FRENCH]
MICHEL ROUX JR: [FRENCH]
London, of course.
What Alain sees in London is
a great, vibrant city-- a city
that now has embraced food,
wine, and all the finer
things of life that we love.
And he's excited, genuinely
excited, about London.
He loves London.
And he knows London-- maybe not
as well as I do, but almost.
He spends quite a bit
of time in London.
So this book is about that.
And it's about expressing the
vibrancy of this great city.
It's not just restaurants.
There are--
ALAIN DUCASSE: [SPEAKING FRENCH]
MICHEL ROUX JR: So every
place listed in the book
is usually led by a
personality, by somebody
who has got character,
and somebody
who believes in what he does.
And that's very much
the strength of the-- it
might be just a cafe.
It might be just a bar.
It might be just a wine shop.
It could be a restaurant.
I'm in there.
It could be a high
end restaurant,
or it could be just a very, very
straightforward little Italian
shop that serves
the best espresso.
But it's with love,
and it's good,
and it's got something there.
It's got a heritage.
So that is what the
book is all about.
"I Love London."
I genuinely do love London.
It's a great, great book.
And it's fun.
And I think what's great
about the book is that you've
captured, in the
photography, the real feel.
It's not a staid cookbook
that you see dishes close up
and you think, oh
wow, and recipes.
No.
It tells a story.
[FRENCH]
ALAIN DUCASSE: [SPEAKING FRENCH]
MICHEL ROUX JR:
It's exactly that.
London is a melting
pot, as we all know.
And the question
I get often asked
is, what is the
greatest city to eat in?
Is it Paris?
Is it London?
Is it New York?
ALAIN DUCASSE: Tokyo.
MICHEL ROUX JR: Tokyo.
ALAIN DUCASSE: [SPEAKING FRENCH]
MICHEL ROUX JR: To be honest,
I think every city is up there.
Every city is different.
I'm a little bit biased because
I consider myself a Londoner.
But I love going to Paris.
I love going to New York.
And they have
individualities, and that's
what's so beautiful about it.
They are so different.
And you are here
because you're foodies,
because you love food and wine.
And you all know what
we're talking about.
When you go to New York,
the first thing you look up
is, where am I going to
go to dinner tonight.
And Paris, as well.
That's what's so exciting
about these great cities.
Question time, maybe?
A few questions?
FEMALE SPEAKER: We've got some
[INAUDIBLE] around the room.
MICHEL ROUX JR:
[FRENCH] One more thing.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
ALAIN DUCASSE: [SPEAKING FRENCH]
MICHEL ROUX JR:
[SPEAKING FRENCH]
ALAIN DUCASSE: [SPEAKING FRENCH]
MICHEL ROUX JR: So future
projects coming up soon.
[FRENCH]
ALAIN DUCASSE: [SPEAKING FRENCH]
MICHEL ROUX JR:
[SPEAKING FRENCH]
ALAIN DUCASSE: [SPEAKING FRENCH]
MICHEL ROUX JR: 12th of May.
In the Bulgari
Hotel, Knightsbridge.
Beautiful hotel, actually.
And called Rive--?
ALAIN DUCASSE: Rivea.
MICHEL ROUX JR: That's
another difficult one.
ALAIN DUCASSE: [SPEAKING FRENCH]
MICHEL ROUX JR: Rivea.
So bringing a little bit of
the southern France sunshine
to British produce.
So I think that sounds
very exciting and very
Alain Ducasse.
ALAIN DUCASSE: [SPEAKING FRENCH]
MICHEL ROUX JR: You can
almost taste the sunshine,
I think is--
ALAIN DUCASSE: [SPEAKING FRENCH]
MICHEL ROUX JR: [FRENCH]
Yeah, absolutely.
Good, so something
very exciting,
and something to
look forward to.
ALAIN DUCASSE: [SPEAKING FRENCH]
MICHEL ROUX JR:
Passionate, passionate chef
he's put in place.
A young man that's worked
in some illustrious places,
including Alain's.
And he is extremely passionate
for the flavors of Provence,
or the flavors of France.
So expect sunshine
on your plate.
Good, questions, yes.
Gosh.
You lot.
Ah, here we go.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
here in Google.
And we're a wonderful
technology company.
I'm interested to know if
when you go to a new city,
what technology do you use
to find new restaurants?
ALAIN DUCASSE: [SPEAKING FRENCH]
MICHEL ROUX JR:
[SPEAKING FRENCH]
ALAIN DUCASSE: [SPEAKING FRENCH]
MICHEL ROUX JR:
[SPEAKING FRENCH]
ALAIN DUCASSE: [SPEAKING FRENCH]
[LAUGHTER]
MICHEL ROUX JR:
[SPEAKING FRENCH]
ALAIN DUCASSE: [SPEAKING FRENCH]
MICHEL ROUX JR: I don't
know if you got all that,
but he's got offices
all over the world.
And the people that
work for him seriously
like to eat and drink out, so--
ALAIN DUCASSE: [SPEAKING FRENCH]
MICHEL ROUX JR: I think
that's the best, isn't it?
It really is.
It's personal
recommendation, basically.
And so the buzz, the
buzz of the atmosphere.
This is the place to go and eat.
This is-- and Alain is
very much like all of us.
We all do the same.
Yes, we may go on to various
websites, or whatever,
but personal recommendation
is always the best.
ALAIN DUCASSE: [SPEAKING FRENCH]
MICHEL ROUX JR:
Otherwise, Google.
ALAIN DUCASSE: [SPEAKING FRENCH]
MICHEL ROUX JR: It's very
true, what Alain says.
He says that in our industry,
we are very close-- very close
together.
And he trusts his
fellow chefs to give him
the right information to go and
eat in such and such a place.
Other than all the buzz
created by the media,
and by newspapers, and such
like about the industry--
about inter-fighting
or whatever,
or being the best restaurant,
this, and various lists
of top restaurant in the
world, or this restaurant--
above that, between
us we communicate.
And it's very, very close.
He thinks that it's probably
one of the few crafts,
or industries, where
we are so close,
and communicate so closely,
and respect each other.
Maybe in medicine, he said,
there is such a feeling.
Another question?
Someone got another?
Yes, young lady over there.
AUDIENCE: I was just
wondering how long
it took to find all the
places and restaurants,
and was there a
team working on it?
MICHEL ROUX JR:
[SPEAKING FRENCH]
ALAIN DUCASSE: [SPEAKING FRENCH]
MICHEL ROUX JR: About two years.
And I think that's an average
for books, about two years.
Two years from conception,
and then a year
to actually bring
it all together.
And like he said, it's
not easy because chefs
have got pretty unusual diaries.
And some chefs are
more or less organized.
And so it's not always
easy, not always easy.
But about two years.
ALAIN DUCASSE: [SPEAKING FRENCH]
MICHEL ROUX JR:
Alain's very humble.
He said he didn't do
it all by himself.
He's got a team there behind
him that obviously put forward
lots of different addresses.
But he says, there could
be 100 more addresses
in this particular book.
But it's just to show the
diversity and the greatness
of London-- showing off what
London has got best to offer.
But it could be even
bigger, he says.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
You talked a little bit
about the personalities
and the venues you visited.
I'm really conscious we're
all in food together.
And there's the food, the
service, and the experience.
And I'm really interested
in your thoughts on food
experience and how
that's changing
as you go around these venues.
And how, in my
opinion, the experience
is becoming a lot more
important than it used to be.
MICHEL ROUX JR: So
experience as a whole?
AUDIENCE: Well, yeah
the environment,
the service, as
well as the food.
MICHEL ROUX JR:
[SPEAKING FRENCH]
ALAIN DUCASSE: [SPEAKING FRENCH]
MICHEL ROUX JR:
[FRENCH] Alain thinks
that it should be majority
percentage of satisfaction
of the food.
So the food, or whatever you're
eating, has to be memorable.
And then the rest,
obviously, is the package,
is the environment-- so
the decor, the staff--
to make up that whole package
and that whole experience.
And it doesn't matter if
it's Michelin Starred--
the high end-- or even
a little bar or a cafe.
It has to be that kind of mix,
and agreed that is a package.
It's not just food led.
AUDIENCE: You can't turn
the television on these days
without falling over, yes,
another cookery program.
Some of which are
better than others.
MICHEL ROUX JR:
Where is this going?
AUDIENCE: But my
question is, is that
having an impact on
the quality of people
coming into the trade?
And a second,
supplementary question
is, do you think that's
changing the way-- particularly
in the UK-- British
consumers are
approaching going
to restaurants?
Are our expectations rising?
MICHEL ROUX JR:
[SPEAKING FRENCH]
ALAIN DUCASSE: [SPEAKING FRENCH]
MICHEL ROUX JR:
[SPEAKING FRENCH]
ALAIN DUCASSE: [SPEAKING FRENCH]
MICHEL ROUX JR:
[FRENCH] Alain says yes
because it creates
a buzz, creates
a certain want
from the people who
are watching their television
to go to this place
or to be interested
more in food.
The second part of your
question was, is it--
AUDIENCE: Two parts.
One was, are you
seeing better quality
people coming into the industry.
And then the other one is
the customer expectation.
MICHEL ROUX JR:
[SPEAKING FRENCH]
ALAIN DUCASSE: [SPEAKING FRENCH]
MICHEL ROUX JR: I mean it does.
The way I see it, it certainly
does bring in some youngsters
into our industry, which
can only be a good thing.
However, some of them
come into our industry
for the wrong reasons.
They think that they can
be the next Jamie Oliver,
Gordon Ramsay, me.
[LAUGHTER]
MICHEL ROUX JR: Be the next me.
ALAIN DUCASSE: [SPEAKING FRENCH]
MICHEL ROUX JR: But
the problem with that
is, they don't realize
that Jamie Oliver, Gordon
Ramsay, Michel Roux
worked their ass off--
worked damn hard to
get to where we are.
Television came later.
So those youngsters that
come into the industry
on the false pretense--
on the pretense of being
the next television chef--
they normally get it wrong,
and they go away
very, very, very soon.
Personally, I do think
that it's a good thing.
But not all programs.
I don't know if you guys know
about my spat-- recent spat--
with the BBC.
I walked away from them.
But that's another story.
That's just editorial policy and
the BBC being very pig-headed.
Just needed to get it
off my chest, sorry.
But I will do something.
I will do something
else, maybe with Google.
Who knows?
You do TV, or that
kind of stuff.
It's interesting.
But I do believe,
like Alain, that media
plays a very strong
part in our industry
for the stuff
coming in, but also
for the public because
there is an interest.
They see the food.
And I see this in
England, especially,
where if I take an example
of snails-- 20 years ago,
you put snails on
the menu in England,
and we just wouldn't sell it.
It wouldn't go.
Or you would occasionally
get people who would buy it,
but it-- no.
And if you asked the
customer, why would
you not want to eat snails?
The answer was, I
don't like them.
Have you tried them, sir?
No, I just don't like them.
Now it's totally different.
The British public
want to try them.
They are curious.
And that curiosity
has come through media
and through wanting to
learn and wanting to taste.
And that's been television
led and media led.
ALAIN DUCASSE: [SPEAKING FRENCH]
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
FEMALE SPEAKER: One more
question. [INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: Hi, thanks
for joining us.
Can you tell us about
a restaurant experience
that you've had recently
that you really enjoyed,
and what it was that
made it for you?
MICHEL ROUX JR:
[SPEAKING FRENCH]
ALAIN DUCASSE: [SPEAKING FRENCH]
MICHEL ROUX JR:
[SPEAKING FRENCH]
ALAIN DUCASSE: [SPEAKING FRENCH]
MICHEL ROUX JR: It's a
slightly off the beat answer,
but Cecile-- Alain's
assistant-- said to him one day,
look, I've got this new
address, this new place,
that you've got to try
when you're in Kyoto.
And as it happened, two weeks
later, he was going to Kyoto.
ALAIN DUCASSE: [SPEAKING FRENCH]
MICHEL ROUX JR: So he takes
the address on the card,
and comes by taxi,
and it just looks
like there's nothing there.
ALAIN DUCASSE: [SPEAKING FRENCH]
MICHEL ROUX JR: So only when
he had pulled this door open
that he saw a
table that was laid
and one chef standing to
attention that he realized
that actually, we were
in the right place.
This was the right address.
ALAIN DUCASSE: [SPEAKING FRENCH]
MICHEL ROUX JR:
That's unbelievable.
It was a vegan restaurant
so absolutely no animal
protein whatsoever.
And this chef had studied
in this particular style
of Japanese food for 20 years.
And he said it was a
mind-blowing experience.
So there you have it.
Alain Ducasse eating vegan food.
That's shock horror.
But I must say I had a similar
experience just outside Tokyo,
as well.
And it was in an old
Buddhist community.
And it was a vegetarian
tasting menu.
And it was extraordinary.
So this is probably one
step further, vegan.
But it goes to prove
that you don't actually
need to eat animal
protein every day.
We were talking about this
just before we came in here.
And this is another
passion of Alain's, and it
is the future-- what
the future holds
not just for our industry,
but as a population,
a global population--
the fact that we really
should be looking at
what we're eating very,
very closely because we are
going to run out of food.
And the need to eat
animal protein--
do we really need to eat
chicken every day of the week?
And no, we don't.
Let's eat chicken once a week.
But let's make it a
really good chicken.
ALAIN DUCASSE: [SPEAKING FRENCH]
MICHEL ROUX JR: Wow.
So Alain, ever the
businessman, was intrigued.
Because how can you run
a business like this?
How can you run a
successful restaurant?
And he asked the owner and
said, well, how do you survive?
How do you keep
this place going?
And he said, well, tonight
is my very last night.
Once you're finished,
I close the door.
Finished.
ALAIN DUCASSE: [SPEAKING FRENCH]
[LAUGHTER]
[APPLAUSE]
MICHEL ROUX JR: Isn't
that a lovely story?
That's a lovely story.
So for those of you who
didn't quite get it,
the chef closed the door
and to go full circle,
he will be working for Alain
Ducasse as from next week.
ALAIN DUCASSE: [SPEAKING FRENCH]
MICHEL ROUX JR: He's
starting on Friday
working for Alain Ducasse.
And I'm sure he will
be a huge success.
ALAIN DUCASSE: [SPEAKING FRENCH]
MICHEL ROUX JR: It is.
And that's just it.
This wouldn't have been
capable of-- we wouldn't
have been able to do
this 20 years ago.
But now, how the
world has changed,
and how Japan has changed
very much, as well.
They are no longer insular,
they have opened up to this.
And so now we can cross over--
France, England, and Japan,
and all these wonderful melting
pots-- and share our knowledge,
and share our cuisine together.
ALAIN DUCASSE: [SPEAKING FRENCH]
MICHEL ROUX JR:
Artisinal Google, yes.
FEMALE SPEAKER: We're just going
to take one final question.
AUDIENCE: Hi, I'm interested in
Alain's vision for the future,
actually.
So what food will we
be eating and talking
about in five or 10 years time?
ALAIN DUCASSE: [SPEAKING FRENCH]
MICHEL ROUX JR:
[SPEAKING FRENCH]
ALAIN DUCASSE: [SPEAKING FRENCH]
MICHEL ROUX JR: It's
very, very important,
and I touched on it earlier.
Alain thinks that us, as
chefs, have a responsibility,
as well to get this
message across--
that we cannot carry
on eating as we do now.
So we must cut back
on animal protein,
less salt, sugar,
fat, et cetera.
Because the world
will run out of food.
It's quite simple.
So we have to re-educate.
We have to re-educate everyone,
and to be less wasteful,
and to eat well.
Because there is
famine about now,
but there could be a lot more.
Does that answer your--
AUDIENCE: Yes, thanks.
FEMALE SPEAKER:
Thank you so much.
It was really, really wonderful.
We have an expression
here in Google,
which is the Google 10 Pounds,
which is the weight that you
gain when you come to work here.
[FRENCH] I think I gained
a few pounds just listening
to the chefs talk here.
And so we'd like to
say, really, thank you.
It was wonderful
to listen to you.
Thank you for coming to
spend the time with us.
Chef Ducasse is going to be
signing his book outside.
So for those of you
who have bought it
or would like to
buy it, he's going
to spend a little bit of
time signing some books.
And also, we're just going
to finish with a video
that Chef Ducasse would like
to share with you on chocolate
manufacturers.
So cue the video.
And thank you so much.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[SPEAKING FRENCH]